[Music]
so maybe the second question most common
question I get is about role identity
especially for women and so when I met
you you're way smarter than
me yep not indicative of that one class
that we had where I got an A and you got
a
B after the professor tried to fight me
but it's cool and so then the next um
that that was incredible that was one of
my favorite moments of my life I know um
25 years ago Hey listen I can't let go
that in high school football games I
can't let them go then you went and got
a master's
degree and you're the only person at the
time that I knew probably to this day
still that got a master's degree because
you want to be a better teacher you were
a school teacher like I want to do this
better and so we lived right down the
street from this major research
University and so and then you went go
got a PhD and it was never in your mind
like I want to go be a research
professor and do all stuff it was like I
want to continue to be much better at
this and I never heard you say like I
want to be a principal or anything like
I just want to I want to learn so much
so I can love these kids and then I got
a job in another city
and you applied to all these it was a
small Texas town so you applied to all
these places and all these school
districts and they wouldn't hire you
because not even an interview yeah
because it was it was she ain't from
around here and it was just like
wait what look at the credential like n
she's not she's not one of us but you
the two job offers you got were the two
major universities in that City and so
you launched into this career where you
became like an absolute gangster at
research professor and I would still be
piding around with my Master's Degree if
you hadn't been hading to blaz that
trail ahead of me because I didn't even
know what some of the words meant and I
didn't know where they posted the
assignment boards I didn't know any of
that stuff almost overnight you become d
Dr deloney
and like the most revered and feared
education professor in that building
like your colleagues would tell you that
same thing you start writing like
research articles you're like presenting
across the country like all of a sudden
this thing that people work their whole
career for you Walt stried in and were
pretty incredible you had an awesome
team that supported you I would say I
Walt stried in but go ahead I'm saying
like it wasn't the intention right like
it wasn't like from day one that wasn't
the dream I'm going to go do this it was
like all right here's this incredible
opportunity and within four or five
years I mean you were it was
unbelievable right um the univers like
senior leadership was pulling you into
meetings and putting you on committees
and and your colleagues respected you
nationally
respected and then you're married to a
guy that went crazy and yeah a little
bit and so like I this is one of my big
like shame pillars that still haunts me
a little bit so you have this incredible
really life right we got Hank he's a
little bitty kid and the whole Community
loves him the university community all
the students all of our students love
him um he's like all your colleagues
especially but all of our colleagues
love him and he's just kind of waltzes
around on a college campus just
surrounded by love and his um school was
like we I walked him to school and would
walk to campus and so we just had this
perfect little life except that your
husband went mad right Stone mad which
it means the life wasn't perfect it
wasn't perfect right right um and so we
left we took a $70,000 household income
pay cut and we moved to another city
three hours away where I was got a new
job at a university that's still on on
its face was a fancy pants job but it
was worth a much smaller group of
students and it was going to give me
some space to like get well figure out
what in the world's going
on and in that transition you made the
choice to not
pursue like working at a university
anymore but like hey I'm going to stay
at home and I'm going to have kids kids
and we're going to have multiple kids
and I'm going to work parttime at a
local school and I remember watching
with awe as you navigated the toggle of
Dr delone Dr delone Dr delone to hey
Miss like right there right Dr delone
from graduate students and you know
President of University to hey Miss by
kindergartner who was super
disrespectful and like a classroom
teacher who was like oh my gosh she's
just an aid right and I watched like uh
like you know as I'm in my own chaos
trying to get well and I'm watching you
ping pong this thing back and forth and
then we you know and I've talked a
little bit about like you know we had
several miscarriages in a row and
navigating grief on top of hey Miss on
top of what are we going to be and it
just felt like you wore a lot when it
came to Identity and then we pack up and
move and I get we get our Dream
opportunity in Nashville and at a
university and then
now as Hank says I'm a YouTuber and I do
a whole other job but it's afforded us a
different kind of life and so in this
last season you you know become a
bestselling author and you've you went
got your master gardener license and
you're Drive 17 hours a day getting kids
all over creation because we live out in
the woods
um how do you navigate how have you
navigated if I look back over the last
10 years that's a lot it's a lot not
just professionally it's a lot of
identity
shifting
how do you navigate that that was a lot
it was of
question uh I'll take it in stages I
guess so the shift from University to
public school part-time hourly worker
that was that was a lot of ego
shift um like you said I I had status I
had autonomy and then I went to like
sign your time sheet and not invited to
any meetings of any
significance even though I may have been
the most qualified person in the
building maybe not but it yes you are it
felt like it at times um and so that was
hard at the same time it's what I wanted
that the thing that didn't happen is I
kind of took this leap from Identity as
a professor to Identity as more leaning
into the stay-at-home mom thing but then
our oldest started school and there was
no other baby yeah to hold and so there
was a gap between the identity that I
left and the identity I wanted to embody
and there was a gap and so that was the
hardest season because I had let go of
one and hadn't grabbed on no Vine coming
right yeah there's nothing coming not
that having only one child makes you
less of a mom or less whatever but he
started school and so those yeah like
the actual hours of the day and it was
hard too in terms of ego I would go to
dinners with you where before we kind of
walked into a room like a work event we
kind of walked in as as a power couple
which you know when I was 30 that there
was mutual respect it was the doctor's
delone right yes and we both had she's
the stable one he's the neurotic one but
they're both yeah yeah we both had
research
and our vas looked good and whatever um
and so then to go if I went with you to
a work event it was oh there's John's
wife and that was like what um oh yeah
or you know inevitably the person
sitting next to you at the chicken and
rice dinner would say what do you do and
it like I used to be a yeah yeah it
stung like I used to be but I'm not
quite it was just a g yeah yeah so that
was a tough one the transition when we
moved here I had already
reestablished a healthier I think or or
maybe not healthier but just a second
half of life kind of identity that
wasn't so wrapped up in what am I going
to tell people at a dinner or how do
people see me when we walk into a room
but just I have figured out who I am who
I want to
be and that ID didn't transfers you know
wherever you want to go whatever however
you're making your
money
um I felt I felt more solid in
mechanistically my identity how did you
unhook that cuz that most most people go
to the grave in that Gap um I I talk
often
about 60-year old guys still telling
High School football stories cuz that's
the last time they had an identity
bigger than themselves right or the
folks who veterans that I've worked with
it's like 25 years ago was your last
deployment and that's still the story of
who you are right um how did you make
that switch because that that buries
most people yeah um part of it's therapy
for sure and then part of it um in that
Gap um my grandma was her health was
declining she was in the last years of
her life dementia was um you know kind
of taking over
and so I felt as I was grieving my
own pregnancy losses I was also grieving
the loss of my grandma
who um is just such a an important
figure in my life and so realizing like
oh any kids I have at this point aren't
going to know her and she's not going to
know them and there was the grief in the
loss of that um so in that time you know
actually right around the time when
Josephine was born I started writing my
grandma's
stories because I wanted our kids I
wanted my cousin's kids I I wanted
people to know her stories and her mom's
stories and the these weren't these
weren't tidy lives they lived they were
they were pioneers and they lived hard
lives but they did it with so much joy
and optimism and and love and and care
and so I started writing down those
stories and I realized oh this is giving
me so much life back because um when you
have small children and a husband who
may have
ADHD everything you do in a day gets
undone like you change diapers you cook
meals you do
laundry pick up the house and the next
day there's a dirty diaper and a pile of
laundry and dirty dishes in the sink and
someone needs a snack
and so it just felt
like you know I I know the stuff about
like pouring into your kids and all that
but on a day-to-day
basis nothing sticks wor it's all it all
has to be done again the next day but I
found that when I got up to write if I
wrote 500 Words that morning those 500
words were still there the next day and
I could build on them and so building a
Writing Practice was really
um getting my life back and
claiming claiming a piece of the day for
myself um you know it reactivated that
that intellectual side and I think for
the first time really turned on a
creative side that I hadn't you know in
in academic writing it's mostly
straightforward
and um it's not as creative in the same
kind of way and so um I found my
creative voice and I realized I can
connect these Generations that won't
know each other and won't meet each
other but I can connect to them and then
in a larger sense uh connect my
grandma's Life and Legacy to to a
broader audience too so here's a big
secret that nobody knows actually
probably everybody knows but especially
the first like nine months I was doing
this show I've got all this expertise
sitting with people I see expertise like
from clinical I mean from a clinical and
academic standpoint but like years of
practice just sitting with folks and I
would get such and such a call like um
they would you know Kelly or Jenna would
send the calls this Kelly back in she'd
send the calls hey this call is what's
coming tomorrow and I would ask you like
hey this person's said this this and
this and this I'm thinking about saying
whatever and you would say oh good God
do not say that God help you don't say
that why don't you ask him this and this
and I was like oh that's genius and and
so like this is just us being as honest
as we can you're a way better writer
Than Me by a long shot my mom called
this week and she's editing your new
book she called this week and was like
hey this is amazing I quit editing it
and I just started reading it and I just
sat there and read the whole thing
through like just in an honest honest
way you could probably do this job
better than me no not that all the
peripheral stuff yeah but when it comes
to like hey what should I say why don't
you ask him this I'm like oh that's
genius right or when it comes to writing
here's your husband getting prayed
around on the bestseller lists and like
she look how many books we sold this
month and how do you handle that because
I know it sucks like there's a there's a
good part because we share the same
checking account and yes we do you know
my my boss flies us around the country
sometimes and that's awesome
but there's like a reality to that yeah
and that's when I'm
still uh still in the
Reckoning yeah but again it goes back to
I have a core
identity um so so yes it's hard to be an
indie author and I have to hire someone
to edit and do cover design and I do all
of my own marketing which is the only
reason I agreed to be on your
podcast
um and so there's that and then you have
people who just like just a machine that
just does all of this and it's amazing
to watch and I I find when I find myself
saying must be nice that's not me being
mad at you that's me being jealous and
the flip side of that is I would never
trade with you because I have absolute
autonomy I make all the final choices in
my business and you have to have your
face on your cover of every book right I
have to fight for everything I get to
choose an artist to do the cover of my
book so a different kind of artist I
guess um so I would never trade
that ever um I set my own schedule and I
see fewer clients in the summer so that
I can have flexibility with our kids
like I I get to make all the choices and
I think for me autonomy is is maybe the
the highest value and what I'm looking
for in and autonomy is a privilege too
though right yeah for sure privilege I
mean your path has led me to this place
where I can have that privilege and and
you know being an IND author is not
going to pay all our bills so I couldn't
do it at all if it weren't for year half
of the the
partnership but it sounds like you're
holding both and that's like it's I to
me I think both and solve so much of
what's going on in our discourse in the
country and in our homes and in our
marriages and with our kids it's like I
feel this way and I'm g go into the next
yeah right thing yeah yeah it also you
know sometimes it
does
um yeah I I struggle with the fact that
our daughter never met me when you were
a gangster yeah yeah but you're a
gangster now it's just a different kind
of gangster
yeah yeah um she did ask one day in the
car if you had a business what would you
call it I said well actually I do have a
business and I got to name it if you
were a doctor what kind would you be
well I am one so yeah um and so
sometimes it surprises me like oh yeah
you never knew you never knew that part
um you've probably shared this story but
she does think well she doesn't anymore
but there was a moment when she thought
I was famous and you weren't pretty
awesome
because she saw me signing books for a
friend and her eyes got wide and she
said are you famous and our friend of
course answered yes did you not know
your mom's famous and that was news to
her news to me too but she had never
heard anyone say that you're famous and
she's never seen you sign books so um
yeah when I brought my book in I was
like I wrote one and she goes dad that's
not a real book like your face is on it
counts and she's like it doesn't count
dad and she's holding on to that she
will not let you yes have that
no and she gets up from her mom yes it's
her best quality
yeah